what would you do if they if MGB came to
you and is like okay we're doing Jersey
Shore 2.0 kids are going together oh my
kids kid you're not no no no no it's
been a year since Jersey Shore star
Ronnie Magro became a dad welcoming
daughter Ariana with on-again off-again
girlfriend
Jen Harley in Las Vegas I'm really
excited for everyone to meet the baby
those are her aunt and uncle I'd be like
one big shy this functional family
[Music]
oh my god now the 33 year old reality
star is navigating life as a single dad
only et was invited into the home he
shares with his baby girl for a
wide-ranging conversation about
co-parenting overcoming depression and
when he plans to let Arianna see Jersey
Shore for herself
[Music]
so did you design this nursery no this
was her mom where does mom live now she
has her own house that's close by yeah
but this was the one that you guys
brought the baby home yeah yeah yeah
this is her her house I bought this for
her that was wanted her to just have a
home you have fun dressing her me hi
just one shot me free yeah joy buying
clothes right yeah what do you like to
pick about this today for her no it's
definitely not when I go show them your
other toys that's yeah for any of these
a gift from their house me Oh Nicole
bordered the little balls
yeah she bought him like a hundred balls
is like thanks Nicole appreciate it
god I just wore her like one two like
two weeks before like oh great I'll be
picking up balls for freaking days at a
time my whole day is just sitting around
waiting to see when she's gonna take a
nap that's right chasing her out so
she's ready to fall asleep yeah and then
I get an hour break and we do it all
over again tell me how his father had
changed you my father had changed me a
lot I feel like that it's given me
purpose is giving me meaning that I've
done so many different things because of
Jersey Shore and things that I've done
that I couldn't even dream about and you
know this and the feeling you get from
that or just like wow but the feeling
you get from being a father is just it
surpasses that like so many times you
know what type of father are you me I
feel like I'm like a mom father you know
doing things for myself it's like you
know I've done so much for myself that I
feel like I need to sacrifice the next
couple years to just you know doing what
I can to be the best father and be the
best role model so that when she does
grow up she could like you know I want a
guy that's like my father you know let's
talk about your relationship though with
her mom what is the status of your
relationship today um you know right now
if she she's always gonna be the mother
of my child and you know I feel like me
and her were always gonna have the love
for each other but I think we're just at
a point that you know
I think we're just trying to figure our
selves out and you know I think right
now we're both happier in the situation
that we're in you know and I have a lot
of time to focus on myself and focus on
my daughter and focus on work and I
think that right now that's the best
place and the best mind state for me to
be in to be honest with you and tell me
about the custody arrangement that you
have you know we have we share 5050 plus
okay so you're with do you do like
Monday Wednesday Friday every other
weekend we're so hectic every tot I just
work with each other and you know I have
something to do she'll watch it if I'm
here I'll take her for extra time
because I know that I'm gonna be gone
for how many days or a week I like that
how do you plan to kind of address the
tumultuous side of your relationship
with Ariana because she is gonna see it
someday she's gonna see the news reports
um she can learn this is what I don't
want to do you know it's a good example
of like you know just do the opposite of
what we did just grow up and know that
you know people make mistakes and the
mistakes they make don't define where
they are so I also understand that
because she's gonna make mistakes in her
life and I don't want to think when she
makes a mistake that it's the end of the
world right no she's gonna get through
it she's gonna push through and things
are always gonna be okay
how have you and Jen been able to kind
of put aside your differences for the
sake of Ariana and making us a peaceful
situation I think we just got to a point
where we just realized that it's not
about us anymore
you know it's about her you know we have
to put our feelings aside she's getting
to that age where she can feel if we're
in a bad mood she knows if we're arguing
or not she knows if we're not arguing if
we're not talking it's like I don't
really want to give off that energy to
her anything you know it's just getting
to that age where she's such a happy
baby and I don't want to take that from
her I feel like last year was just a lot
you know stuff that was going on the
show was just a whirlwind there you know
that's really it was like the money
machine but it was just like you're like
but you don't want to catch it so you're
swatting it away instead of grabbing the
money that's basically what it was like
no you know it I can't really blame the
show for the things that I did you know
I still might actually still were what
they were I still did what I did and
that's what it is and I have to own it
be a man you know I can't run from my
problems because they're always going to
be there you have had a difficult year
we've seen a lot of it play out on TV
but how has being a father in
acted your choices and your behavior in
the last year yeah I feel like before
you're a parent and especially in the
lifestyle I live you have to have a
mentality of not really caring right so
you get to a point where because if you
listen to everything somebody said you
drive yourself crazy so you get to a
point where you don't care and I think
that's the point that I was at the last
year me and then came my daughter and
then you know I started to realize like
it's not about you anymore now it's
about the decisions you make that are
gonna affect her like wow like I have to
watch what I do because now I'm you know
I'm in control of this little person's
life you know and it's not just me
anymore right now I hear your little
girl is right over here I can hear her
should we bring your oh do you credit in
this little one with getting your life
on track yeah she definitely is keep my
little crazy
I'm tired show it off right now that's
all right
do you want to see a new toy I brought
you a present
oh it's a narwhal lots of pretty colors
do you like that hey thank you oh my
gosh how much fun is that
so do you expect to have more babies do
you want more kids
honestly I've wanted to spoil her yeah
right now I just really want to just
focus on her and just yeah you know I
feel like another kid right now would
just be a little bit too much do you
want me to hold you I'll hold you wow
this chairs hiding I hate you up high
high a whole tree sweet girl okay do you
wanna help me ask the questions yeah
what should we ask next what do you
think she says no more babies I'm the
only how about this one what advice what
advice did uncle Paulie and aunt Snooki
and Aunt Jenny give when it was time
basically like Paul he just basically
told me you know like like I said every
decision that I make you know I have to
realize and I have a daughter now you
know and a lot of things that on TV a
lot of things you say like especially
our show it's so popular that eventually
that she's gonna see it you know and
it's you know you got to be careful with
the way you act know you things because
it's gonna portray to her and then she
has to grow up with that absolutely the
day she's the ones walking around like
that's my dad or that's my mom so really
it's a lot of pressure well let's talk
about that when are you gonna let her
kind of see what I got there what do you
mean well I mean listen we've got the
show we've got years of archival footage
of dad being a little craziness we've
got some footage of dad and mom having
some crazy time out there
have you thought have you and Jen talked
about when that there might be an
appropriate time to leave her in when
she's older you know 15 16 yeah the
problem is that there is the internet
right you know so parental controls
right parental controls yeah well you
like block the Google search of course
canceling cable Ariana's already a
natural in front of the cameras but she
still needs an app there's such a ham
yeah you didn't take a nap
early on it tell me what we can expect
in the new season well the new season is
basically gonna be a lot of the stuff
that did happen last year you know in
the beginning and then the tribe I
figure I think towards the end of this
is gonna be more of the progression of
what's going on now Dina's behaving a
khole having the kid you know what I'm
going through right now is a father and
stuff like that you're still filming yes
we're still filming yes I'm still young
even this 145 seasons I gotta be honest
we're a lot of like Ronnie having a hard
time yeah a lot of it well the Ronnie
Magro family vacation they call it on
the media they call the production calls
at that it's it's not a good thing that
last season was just I was just going
through a lot of stuff you know I had a
lot of anger and I was going through a
serious case of depression that I didn't
even know that I was going through until
I addressed it and then I was just like
wow like um you know I really have
depressed yeah you know like and I've
never felt that before because you know
so young when we got Jersey Shore and it
was like you're on top of the world and
it's like you have everything and you
meeting all these people and doing all
this stuff it's like what do I have to
be the pressed about and then I guess
life kind of set in I didn't realize it
and then I was just like wow like wow
this is like this is real you know and
then you know I did when I got help and
I think that was just the best thing for
me to just get myself out of the toxic
situation that I was here right whether
it was the things I was doing or the
things that you know Ariana's mom was
doing it was just like I had to kind of
just pull myself out and just reset you
know and kind of just do as much work as
I can on myself and really just be like
you know life isn't that bad you know
I'm not a victim to life you know I have
blessings I have a beautiful daughter
you know I have a great job I have a
great support system so it was like
instead of focusing on the one negative
thing let's focus on the 30 positive
things
how is everybody supporting Mike I know
that's gonna be a big storyline
he really has change his life around and
he's really become an amazing person and
you know just just all the work that
he's done on himself and just he's
so positive to be around it just gives
off this great or this great energy I
like when you're around and you're just
like I want that you're all about to go
see him already so you guys will see it
on the new season go to support Mike and
I talked to him through email you know
at least once a week or every other week
and we stay in touch you know and he's
doing right there
he looks good he's getting a situation
back again yeah yeah a BTS anymore
definitely coming back to the situation
yeah for food give it to Big Daddy sitch
you were recently in the news for a
procedure that you had done yes try to
avoid it's a real thing what made you
turn to liposuction um honestly I've
never done any kind of surgery before
and I figured you know this is my
schedule last year was so hectic and
trying to be a dad and all my other
business ventures and filming and and
just try it it's just it's it's a lot
I'm eating hell it just becomes a lot of
work and it was just like you know I
mean if I could just do procedure that
could kind of help me a little bit it's
like why not I feel like women do it all
the time it's awesome I go medicine
cheeks and eyelashes and hair extension
and breasts and button cats like and
fingernails and eyelash I feel like I I
mean I feel like I get like like most
girls are like mr. Potato Head I need to
start pulling pieces off of them at a
time it's like how's it been going I
understand it was a tough recovery for
ya yeah I was one of the doctor said
it's probably one of the worst
recoveries he's seen Haley yeah why my
body just didn't react well I think I
said it was the first surgery I've ever
gone I've never broken a bone or had any
kind of surgery period so I think my
body was just like you
like what are you doing why would you do
this to me well you can't do 30 minutes
of cardio what would you do if your
daughter said that she wanted to have a
procedure done I would just tell her no
how would you say she has saved your
life I feel like she just really made me
want to focus on just being a better
person being a better version of me
whether it is whether it's business or a
father or a boyfriend or a husband it's
just just trying to be the best version
of myself that I can be yeah you know
I'd just be a great role model for
because at the end of the day you know
she's gonna be daddy's little girl you
know I want her to grow up and admire me
and look up to me and be proud of you
know who I am
[Music]